l'homme au fil de ses activités
s'inscrit dans le paysage jusqu'au nom
des lieux de vie souvent évocateur la
minière le marteau C lieudit du Val d'au
bois indique qu'ici la sidérurgie a
forgé la vie des
hommes Aline perderau est animatrice en
architecture et patrimoine passionné du
Val elle sera notre guide dans ce
paysage discret à peine visible du
plateau
on a l'impression d'être dans quelque
chose de très très rural et en fait on
va découvrir petit à petit qu'on a un
paysage industriel caché et si on
regarde bien effectivement au milieu de
cette vallée avec les moutons les champs
on voit ces cheminées au loin qui nous
indiquent un paysage de
l'industrie grosouvre un village
aujourd'hui de 300 âmes qui au 19e
siècle en comptait plus de 1000 dans ce
Val minerais eau bois sont abondants
trois critères déterminants pour que se
développe la sidérurgie dépendante de
l'énergie hydraulique et du
charbon au départ on a une activité
industrielle liée à la métallurgie donc
très très ancienne qui remonte au
biturig même on pe on peut aller assez
loin et puis petit à petit avec
l'extinction des des minerais des
matériaux de la métallurgie on passe à
la fabrication de la tuile et ensuite
début 20e on passe à l'exploitation donc
du calcaire chaud et ciment démarré au
Moyen-Âge la sidérurgie devient dès le
14e siècle l'activité dominante de la
vallée le Val de bois sera à son apogé
au 19e devenant l'une des plus
importantes régions sidérurgique
française le travail est technique et
l'on va jusque dans les îles
britanniques où l'art de la forge est en
pointe pour recruter des ouvriers
qualifié pour retenir cette main d'œuvre
très recherchée les patrons construisent
des logements sur place et déjà début
19e les ouvriers bénéficient
d'appartements confortables en habitat
collectif plus tard pour favoriser la
famille l'habitat individuel sera
privilégié nous partons pour Torteron un
village à 15 km où siège les ruines d'un
hautlieu de la métallurgie appelé la
régie devant les portes du site
industriel Aline retrouve Pauline
architecte pour une visite des lieux si
on remonte vraiment aux origines du du
lieu c'est les les les moines de
laabayli de fondmini à quelques
kilomètres qui avait déjà installé un
moulin à battre le fer et ça a commencé
à ce à cette cette période là voilà 12e
siècle et puis petit à petit au fur et à
mesure des années je dirais le
l'exploitation c'est s'est agrandi et
c'est devenu carrément là une forge
royale au 17e on a fabriqué ici des
bouletes de canon des encres de M marine
et puis comme on parlait tout à l'heure
des tuyaux les fameux tuyaux d'amené
d'eau des villes de Paris et
Madrid si le paysage des Forges s'abîme
et disparaît au fil du temps il reste
Torteron village conçu par les patrons
de la régie dans les années 1850 pour
accueillir 4000 habitants au plus fort
de l'activité seulement 2000 s'y
installeront les patrons organisent la
ville et voi grand tout semble démesuré
comme la place de la Liberté immense
esplanade
vide en fait le la réflexion là elle est
poussée à son maximum puisqu'on dép on
on part d'une d'une ville et de son
dessin justement pour organiser les
choses pour gérer la la vie sociale et
donc gérer l'espace social et la vie
c'est dans la logique
du du mouvement un peu patriarcal que
prenaient les les grosses industries et
qui géraent à la fois l'urbanisme comme
la salle prouve vraiment de de de
complètement de but en blanc et aussi la
vie sociale ainsi l'entreprise pourvoie
au travail au logement s'assure de la
santé de l'éducation et des loisirs des
ouvriers si politique sociale il y a
elle est à l'image de l'organisation
industrielle rentable et sécurisé et
l'urbanisme en est un outil majeur on a
cet axe administratif du travail entre
l'administration la mairie et la régie
l'entrée de l'usine mais on a un axe un
deuxième qui est axe moral et celui-ci
est vraiment déterminé entre deux points
on a l'église la nouvelle église et la
gendarmerie puisque la gendarmerie était
vraiment un point un point d'orgue pour
pour encadrer la vie des ouvriers
beaucoup trop récal citrant au goût des
des patrons de
l'époque le val d'au boois s'est façonné
au gré des l'évolution industrielle
aujourd'hui ce côtoi usine abandonnée ou
en fonctionnement et activité agricole
créant un paysage contrasté inattendu
marqué fortement par son
passé